okay let's try our next caller from the
nine one eight area code caller from
nine one eight tell us your name and
what's uh what's on your mind today yeah
can you hear me yeah we can all right uh
Ben from Oklahoma great and my question
is for both you and Penn it's the
favorite band or artist and favorite
movie oh geez I mean this is for me is
like when someone asked me what's your
favorite book it's like you know if you
read regularly you couldn't possibly
have a favorite book you'd have to tell
me genre or from the last X number of
years or something like that I mean I
like so many bands off in so many movies
do you have like a favorite band or
movie Pat for band I would go with like
Red Hot Chili Peppers maybe Wow yeah
that's hot commercial that's that's made
movie I'm not too much of a movie buff
maybe we'll go with like Back to the
Future Back to the Future interesting
okay yeah I mean the last and this is
crazy but the last movie I saw in a
movie theater was Episode seven of Star
Wars that's the land I think that's it's
been two years since I've been to the
movies I just really don't I just don't
don't go to the movies I don't have much
time but bands I mean my musical
interests are so diverse everything from
you know Led Zeppelin and other 70s rock
all the way through argentinian
alternative and reggae bands you know i
mean i couldn't i couldn't say my
favourite band
Beatles or the Rolling Stones oh I'm big
Beatles over the stone I've never been a
stones guy really I'd much rather the
Beatles huge Beatles fan over stones for
sure okay will you be checking out the
Frank Zappa hologram tour I will not
thank you for checking with me about
that Pat but no you can put that it's
yeah I would say not even cross it off
my list it's never been on my list